le bien-être et la nature au coeur d'un
nouveau quartier de versailles la vie et
les collaborateurs du projet ont dévoilé
à paris les contours du futur site un
espace construit sur une ancienne friche
militaire située au fond du parc du
château qui pourra accueillir 2500
nouveaux habitants dans 5 144 logements
l'ensemble du site aura pour seul mot
d'ordre la zénitude le quartier tout un
écosystème avec à une halte gourmande
100% bio une et des maisons
participative un hôtel d'un nouveau
genre on apprendra aviron environ
l'harmonie avec la nature avec des
espaces de méditation de jeunes un
centre équestre dans lequel on travaille
sur le langage des chevaux une plaine
des sports
autre particularité de cette cité jardin
les voitures seront presque invisible en
l'espace de vingt hectares
seule une rue principale sera ouverte à
la circulation les parkings sont tous
enterrés y compris pour les maisons
individuelles ce qui produit des espaces
paysagers et des rues totalement libre
de la circulation automobile
avec ce neuvième quartier de versailles
son concept idéaliste la municipalité
veut inspirer les villes du futur la
ville moderne c'est la ville écologique
c'est la ville nature et versailles se
veut être au niveau national mais aussi
mondiale un démonstrateur en ce domaine
notre histoire le permet dans l'histoire
de versailles elle est héritée de la
pensée de lenôtre qui la référence dans
le monde sur le paysage est donc entré
dans cette histoire on veut montrer que
versailles reste encore à pointe de la
réflexion
coût total pour cette opération 56
millions d'euros la livraison définitive
du site est programmée à l'horizon 2026